hey what's up Samuel leaves here on the
property investor love to make money in
property love to teach people how to do
the same and I'm going to be answering
some niggly questions this is Q&A Sunday
and I'm gonna try and answer as many of
your questions from the previous weeks
as possible in as short time as possible
so that's keeping super punchy if you
have questions to pop up in your brain
comment your questions below no question
is a stupid question so any questions
you've got at all in property comment
below I always enjoy reading the
questions I'll do my best to answer as
many of them as possible next time so
let's see what we got
send me a great content have you ever
rented out your properties to the local
council I know investors that do this
they get guaranteed rents some of which
after three years they also do repairs
to the house so should the tenants need
it interesting to hear your thoughts
keep up the good work
Adam thank you Adam I appreciate you bro
so yeah I have but more listen if
someone's prepared to give you a
guaranteed rent what that normally means
is normally the gap if they're doing all
the repairs and giving you a guaranteed
rent normally you could get a higher
rent so you could do yourself and get a
higher rent however there's no hassle so
council tenants it is something that I
have done but it's not something that I
do a lot and the reason is is because my
property is normally a professional
houses but what I have done which is the
same same sort thing a lot more often if
I've given my HMO properties to a
company that gives me a guaranteed rent
so basically they're doing a rent to
rent on my house why on earth would I do
that I do that because all I would if I
just moved to London quite recently and
I've got so a lot of my houses and my
team and stuff wearing over Hampton I've
got probably's and snow properties all
over the place and and sometimes it's
just for me it's easier to get a
guaranteed went and I don't care that
they're making four five six hundred
pound a month on me because they're
taking responsibility their debt they're
managing everything they're running the
show at least I'm still making a nice
good profit at least I know exactly
what's coming in so yeah this is great
if you want that guaranteed guaranteed
income and also if you want
if you want to know exactly what's
coming in every month and you don't want
anything to happen like calls from
tenants or call from management
companies your complete passive it's
good really interesting was I was
learning a crash course recently and I
was talking about rent to rents and
someone said oh I'm trying to do a rent
to rent in Birmingham but no one in
Birmingham will do went to rent none of
the landlord's are interested and I'm
thinking well I'm a landlord in
Birmingham and that week I just passed
two of my HMOs on to someone on a renter
met basis and I'm thinking you're just
asking the wrong questions so if you're
looking to do rent to rents you've just
got a bit be reputable ask the right
questions network with the right people
and know exactly what you're talking
about and we're able to provide value
like me I just like to guarantee an
income so I've done both I've done went
to rents passed my hands on winter mints
so I hope that's helpful can you remove
a 75% value of your house worth two
hundred thousand pounds even if your
salary earnings are only fifteen
thousand a year yes if it's buy-to-let
probably a big know if it's residential
so if if you're if you own a house and
you live in it and you want to get a
mortgage on it or we finance it or
whatever the lender cares how much you
earn because this is your home how are
you gonna pay if you refinance it how
you gonna be able to pay the mortgage if
it's a buy-to-let
they don't really care too much about
your earnings if it's fifteen thousand
pound a year you're probably good I
can't give Ben a bespoke mortgage advice
but what I can say is that buy to let
mortgages care more about the property
that you're buying than they care about
you so whereas residential care more
about you if you're living in it so it
depends Matt on mass on whether it's
residential or whether it's buy to let
but speak to a broker always the best
thing to do
Harriett if you had fifty thousand pound
what strategy would you use to invest it
in pens on what wanting to achieve
instead oil am I looking to get cash
flow in which case fifty thousand pounds
I would probably get some really I would
invest fifty thousand pounds you can you
could set up a rent to rent business
with that and go crazy and make twenty
grand a month but it's going to be a lot
of work a lot of effort a lot of systems
what I would probably be most in
quantity or fifty thousand pounds
is by refurbish we financed by a little
cheap house and add value and then pour
as much of my money back out as possible
rinse and repeat and keep going I think
that's just a great strategy I would do
it probably somewhere in the north and
put it one day but it depends on what
you want to achieve but you can do a lot
fifty doesn't matter and with the right
knowledge you can do a lot oh and also
fifty thousand pound with no knowledge
I've been put in at least ten percent of
that into my own education all right
come on West Ham says this is a long one
so I'm gonna skim read this I want to
get a lease option from a vendor through
an estate agent how do I get them to
agree without a fee all right is
actually Maximilian okay I think I get
your question so you're what you're
saying is how do you get a lease option
agreement do you cut the agent out or do
you go straight to the vendor or do you
try and get the estate agent on side
what I do is I cut the agent out I go
straight to the vendor when I want to do
my lease option agreement so I always
want to be dealing with the vendor
direct because the estate agent will be
confused by what a lease option
agreement is and they'll feel threatened
because they want to get their fee and
they're all a bit unsure and there's a
saying that says if you confuse them you
lose them so I want to be dealing with
vendors direct I'm gonna pitch to the
option agreement
nice and simply to them using plain
English not using complex language if
it's on with an agent I'll get the deal
with the vendor direct and then I'll go
to the agent and tell them what I did
and offer to pay their fee sometimes you
can get agents on side by showing them
what you've done rather than telling
them what you want to do so I do a whole
teaching on this at the property
investors crash course so Maximilian if
you've not been to the property
investors crash course get yourself
popped and we'll put a link in the
description below
on me on the house you're gonna friggin
love it at the house all right next to
relaunch bionaire takes another great
video on the tude a crash course in
October
love that good I don't understand people
that don't come to the crash course it's
just nuts people who even flies are
small over the world they're people from
India Australia Hong Kong America all
over Europe so yeah get down you know
whatever you doing on the next day of
the crash course cancel it get down so
look forward to meeting you in October
can you tell me I'll buy to that
mortgage is optional in the sense that
you can do repayment or interest only if
you have the option which one would you
choose yes you have the option and I
would choose interest only every time I
do not want to pay that mortgage off I
want to use all of my money and all of
my cash to buy more houses and not pay
the mortgages off to the houses I
currently own why because it's better
leverage it's better cash flow hope it
helps I'll see you at the crosswalk bro
where is the best area to invest out of
London it depends on what you want to
achieve it depends on what you want to
achieve cash flow capital appreciation
wise what I would say is don't dump it
on those people and jump on the
bandwagon and go oh my gosh
everyone's buying in Manchester
Manchester's going up like crazy at the
moment
I'll buy Manchester because Manchester's
been going up been going crazy to last
three four years it's gonna peak soon
Birmingham is peaking now London peaked
a few years ago find somewhere that's
just about to start
you know predict where where did this
area's bottom down this area's had no
capital appreciation for light years and
then that could potentially be better
well so it's just all about what the
return on investment is so I can't give
one particular area and if I did if I
gave one particular area everyone would
go and invest there and then it probably
wouldn't be that great in two three
years anyway so but hey I'm very
transparent about where I'm buying you
know when I buy houses I'll regularly
vlog it put it out there I just bought
one in Darlington a buy refurbish
refinance and I did a whole vlog on that
you can check that out above there
should be a link somewhere and yeah that
went really well
so Darlington there's one area one
option but this is so many
Oh Marius I literally have 1,000 pound
in my savings and 20 years old
struggling to know what to do
what strategy would you start with
because I obviously don't enough pretty
positive preciate you could have me okay
if you've got 1000 pound and that's it
dude
obviously you don't know that to buy a
house with 1,000 pounds with no
knowledge and no network so I would put
that whole 1000 pound I would put that
into building your network building your
knowledge getting around the right
people I'd use that on I'd use that for
staying at hotels during property
seminars and networking events I'd use
that for joining a local BNI meeting to
get yourself out there I'd use that for
face a facebook video ads to tell the
world that you're a property investor
and then change story I'd use that four
cups of coffee with the investors like I
would just use that 2,000 pound just to
get you through the beginning stages of
just getting into the world and the
right circles of property investors so
that's what I would do
all right Emma any information on we
mortgaging your homes not buy to let
when initially taking the highest
mortgage amount possible for salary
houses increased in price due to
renovations
however salary is not increased and only
owned the house for six months thanks
great good just good that your house is
going to be value I'll probably sell
that baby I probably sell it rent and
then put all the money into goodbye to
let properties personally or just just
tell your boss that you need to pay rise
you know I don't know I don't know what
I would do but it's good that your house
is going up in value or just let the
equity sit there if you can't get it for
now it's still there you're gonna be
able to get it at some point change
strategies start doing lease options and
different things so if that's triggered
more questions comment them below guys
hope you found that useful every single
Sunday I'm answering your questions I
want to see your questions below I read
these every night I scroll through I
read them and I enjoy reading them and I
enjoy answering them so let me see let
me see just shared loads of questions
below I'll be taking as many as I can
next week to answer thanks for watching
if you're not subscribe to the channel
and you watch my videos but please
do you subscribe also turn on the
notification bail as well so that you
don't miss a video because some of these
videos are absolutely gold dust I hope
you would agree thank you for watching
I'll see you next time really appreciate
you guys thank you
[Music]